California the blowme states recently
passed a spate of new laws and boy howdy
are they enforceable for instance you're
no longer allowed to hold your cell
phone while driving that is really gonna
cut into my carpool lane masturbation
but hey the life it saves may be your
own also California uber drivers are no
longer allowed to be sex offenders or
drunk good way to stay ahead of the
curve comedians as California goes so
does the nation and we are a nation of
laws what are some new laws you'd like
to see passed in other states ron
funches in florida it is now legal to
fight with your shirt off and with your
shirt on
[Applause]
in the road a little Florida shirt
there's nothing wrong with that Kyle
Kinane in Massachusetts if you can make
it through a Dropkick Murphys concert
without starting a fistfight you can
skip a child-support payment Alaska go
ahead the Moose we know you're doing it
anyway
[Applause]